witches and wizards let me take you back
in time to October of 2020. you see that
is when I first started making videos
about a little game called Hogwarts
Legacy and in only the second video I
posted about it I went through a list of
10 features that we needed to see in the
final game we did know it in October of
2020 but after a series of delays we
wouldn't see the game for roughly two
and a half years from when I made that
video looking back at the list now I'd
say Avalanche did pretty well they
absolutely nailed Hogwarts Castle made a
combat system that was ridiculously fun
and let us interact with the Wizarding
World like never before Oh and it also
helps that the game has already made
over a billion dollars and that's even
before releasing on the Nintendo switch
so a sequel is all but inevitable and
because of the excellent Foundation
they've already built with Hogwarts
Legacy hopefully we won't be waiting as
long for Hogwarts Legacy too by taking
that foundation and iterating on it in a
few key ways they can create a game that
is true to the original true to the
world they've built but also one that
ultimately ends up being a vastly
superior game when compared to the first
for me it all starts with having a
feature that was one of the weakest
areas of Hogwarts Legacy the lack of a
true morality system we need to see this
in Hogwarts Legacy too after all it is
not our abilities that show what we
truly are it is our choice while we did
have a handful of choices throughout the
game a few of them seem to have any
major impact on the story in fact even
the final Choice ends up being a slight
cutscene change and doesn't seem to
matter much to the world around you
after you make that choice I can only
really think of one choice that felt
like it had a true meaning a true
consequence all of the focus on whether
or not you want to learn the
unforgivable curses barely matter at all
no one in the world seems to care about
a fifth year student roaming free and
casting the unforgivable curses on
anything and everything in their path
and on the other side of that even if
you chose a path of light there were no
rewards no benefits for doing so not in
the gameplay nor in the story now I
think back to 2003 and there was a game
then that absolutely nailed this it's a
little gym called Star Wars Knights of
the Old Republic the morality system
there tracks your choices throughout the
game which include everyday
conversations and then critical plot
decisions as well this all determines
whether you lean towards the path of
light or the path of Darkness it's a
simple scale from 0 to 100 but all
players starting the game at 50. more
really good choices push your number up
and closer to the light where bad
choices give you negative points and
there's even room for the morally gray
players who want to follow their own
code and ignore the traditional beliefs
of the Jedi and Sith As you move further
in one of those directions though the
appearance of your character will
actually change certain abilities are
also enhanced based on the path you
choose and you actually feel like you're
having an impact on the world around you
and the characters inside it most
importantly it's having an impact on you
as a character a true morality system
with meaningful choices would add layers
of complexity to a Hogwarts like a c
sequel a layer of complexity that the
original was sorely lacking we would
actually need to be mindful of our
choices and actions knowing that those
decisions could lead to Lasting
consequences they could change the
course of the story and even influence
the fate of our fellow witches and
wizards now you may ask what's the point
of having all these narrative choices
and key story decisions if our character
doesn't actually have a reason for doing
so in Hogwarts Legacy 2 I would like to
see a stronger storyline where our
character has some sort of past and
again here I Look to Knights of the Old
Republic as a shining example of how you
give a character a strong story but also
give the player the freedom to shape and
mold the character based on their
preferred choices and style of play I
know it's an old game but I still all
these years later do not want to spoil
it if you haven't played it yet I want
to be very careful how much I say here
I'll put it like this your character
starts the game as somewhat of a blank
slate and you're given the ability to
make choices and guide their path but as
the story progresses you're going to
learn more about their past which leads
to one of the best conclusions in all of
video games Hogwarts Legacy wanted to
let players be the witch or wizard they
wanted to be which is ultimately why I
believe they went with a near total
Blank Slate when it comes to our
character's past we don't even know why
they have this ancient magic ability or
how they got it you don't even know if
we have parents but I do think there's
room for more background overall that
would allow the developers to craft a
more engaging and immersive narrative a
more defined backstory would enable the
player to witness the protagonist's
evolution an evolution that would be
based on our choices and decisions in
the game while the Harry Potter series
may be named for the boy who lived the
iconic cast of characters around him
also played a key role in his journey
and I think it should be that way in the
sequel to Hogwarts Legacy as well and
one of the best ways to do this would be
to have a True Companion system where we
can choose between different characters
to accompany us on side quests and join
up with specific characters related to
the story for various main missions
games like Skyrim Mass Effect and yes
Knights of the Old Republic have done an
excellent job with this it would
actually appear this is something the
original Hogwarts Legacy wanted to
implement at least at one time after all
there are quests and missions where we
team up with poppy natsai Sebastian and
yes even a meat to car but the game
stopped short of a True Companion system
where these characters join you on other
missions in fact through a few PC
companion mods fans have found lines of
dialogue that strongly suggest a fully
fleshed out companion system was there
at least at some point in Hogwarts
legacy's development now I don't believe
it should be required for players to
have a companion on every single quest
after all there are some of us who enjoy
tackling missions as a lone wolf but
there's no denying that a companion
system it helped to build the immersion
of the world and make them start to feel
like our own versions of Ron Hermione
and Neville and if they combine this
with the choice in Morality features we
discussed before these companions could
grow alongside our main character and
possibly even gain new abilities or open
up unique story lines another key
component to help build those
relationships is giving players more
time to actually live life as a student
that is if they keep as a student in the
sequel look as much as I loved getting
to freely roam the Scottish Highlands at
any time and I hope that free roaming is
still very much an aspect in the sequel
I definitely think we need more time of
the student life I've recently been
playing a lot of Harry Potter magic
awaken which has turned out to be a much
better game than I ever expected and
that's coming from someone who doesn't
really play mobile games and to this
point I've spent absolutely nothing to
play it it's different from Hogwarts
Legacy in so many ways truth be told I
think some sort of mashup between Legacy
and Magic awaken could actually give us
the perfect Wizarding World game one of
the things magic awakened does so well
is that it really helps you to feel like
a student classes are a key part of the
experience and always available for the
player you can choose to take them with
some of the NPC classmates from the game
or you can actually invite your real
world friends rather than having the
classes at a set time of day they're
open to the player at any time but they
actually do rotate which classes are
available from day to day Legacy had
some good ideas for the classes but most
of them ended up being a one-time
experience and even some of the
enjoyable extracurricular activities
such as summoner's Court they weren't
even repeatable after completing the
mission that corresponded with them the
cross wands dueling Club just completely
gone after you complete that magic
awakened also has some live events that
players can experience in real time with
fellow students such as a fireworks
celebration flying around Hogwarts
Castle you know playing with others from
our community here has been one of the
most enjoyable parts of that new mobile
title and I would love to see Hogwarts
like C2 add some sort of Cooperative
multiplayer mode that can be experienced
with other players from around the world
now don't get me wrong I believe the
core focus of Hogwarts legacy sequel
should remain on delivering a high
quality single player action RPG but
there's definitely something to be said
for a mode that allows some of the most
passionate long time fans of this series
to group up and actually participate in
activities together for me my memories
of this series will always always always
be about Community some of the first
podcasts that I ever listened to were
Harry Potter podcasts probably the only
time in my life that I will ever have
the experience of going to a midnight
book launch happened because of Harry
Potter and so much of this was about
experiencing it with other people the
community now I think ghost of tsushima
on the PS4 gives a fantastic blueprint
for how developers can create a
top-notch single player experience but
then surprise everyone with a standalone
multiplayer mode for those who want to
team up with friends it also helps to
extend the lifespan of the game and keep
the conversation around Hogwarts Legacy
going and WB leadership has already
spoken about how they see Hogwarts
Legacy as a new franchise so it's safe
to say this is a series they're looking
to keep going for years to come there
was even a rumor of a Hogwarts Legacy TV
show at one point if they're going to
grow this franchise to even bigger
Heights they'll need to venture beyond
the walls of just Hogwarts and even
beyond the boundaries of the Scottish
Highlands that's right Hogwarts Legacy 2
needs to add more four iconic Wizarding
World locations for the player to
explore so early in the first game we
made our way through gring Gods which I
thought was a fantastic start to the
game it really helped set this stage for
an Epic Journey Across The Wizarding
World unfortunately outside of the
Scottish Highlands area we don't really
do a lot of traveling in the main game
there are a few memory sequences here
and there oh and if you played as a
Hufflepuff you do get to see Azkaban but
it's very brief a sequel needs to see
entire story lines and missions that
take place in some of the most famous
locations from The Wizarding World such
as Azkaban the ministry of magic Diagon
Alley and possibly even other Wizarding
World schools from around the world as
much as we all love Hogwarts itself and
know that it needs to be Central to the
experience some of the most epic scenes
from the book actually take place in
some of those other iconic locations
traveling to more of these locations
would really help to set the stage for
an even bigger story as that ancient
magic that we learned about in the first
game maybe it actually starts having
Ripple effects throughout the rest of
the world now if we're going to be
venturing into more locations such as
Azkaban then we'll need to add more
spells to our Arsenal combat was
ridiculously fun in the first game and
it would be awesome to see them build on
that core mechanic by adding more spells
such as aguamenti and karstris and
obliviate the one that would be at the
top of my list though you guys already
know it's without a doubt the Patronus
charm we need to see our Patronus in
Hogwarts Legacy too Avalanche made an
incredibly smart move with the first
game by allowing players to link up
their Wizarding World account to the
game which in turn gave us the option to
bring over our house and one from the
website imagine if they took this a step
further in the sequel by bringing over
our Patronus charm this would be more
difficult to pull off as there are
numerous Patronus options fortunately
they all serve the same purpose but
would need slightly different animations
to represent the animal now that I think
about it Hogwarts Legacy should already
have many of these animations thanks to
the vast number of creatures already
included in the original you've got grap
horns Moon calves nifflers measles and
even dragons oh and speaking of dragons
can we please ride them in the sequel
I'll be honest I really thought they
were setting up for an epic conclusion
that had dragon mounts as maybe an
in-game unlock but alas it was not meant
to be while we could ride brooms the
strolls hippogriffs and grab horns and
even though dragons make quite a few
appearances in the game we never
unlocked them as a mount at first it may
not seem like it fits within the world
but even Harry and the trio rode on a
dragon in the final book of the series
and while we're on the topic of rideable
mounts what about being able to cast
spells while we're riding in the next
game for number nine on our list we have
to talk about the need for better loot
in Hogwarts Legacy too the first game
had so many caves and hamlets to explore
a lot of these caves really had fun
puzzles too but some of these areas
aren't even getting seen by players
because they're just not worth it to
explore sure there's treasure and loot
there but rarely is it actually
rewarding players would frequently find
themselves opening loot that was
actually lower in level than what they
already had now these extra items they
don't really even serve much of a
purpose sure you could sell them in
hogsmead and then even use the enchanted
Loom that's in the room of requirement
to enhance certain abilities but
personally I found the game didn't
really present many scenarios where
these upgrades were even needed I
expected to have areas of the game where
I would really need to optimize and
focus on certain pieces of gear that are
going to best help me in that situation
so it'd be great if the sequel had more
enemy variety where there was actually
more strategy to some of this and while
I appreciate the numerous cosmetic
options that were in the game they
really missed having a few standout
items that you could only get in certain
locations games like Dark Souls have
mastered this but they also have the
benefit of letting the player wield a
variety of weapons such as axes swords
bows whereas in The Wizarding World
you're sort of kind of limited to just a
wand this is where Avalanche would
really need to think outside the box
figure out ways to make the loot more
rewarding overall to be fair The
Wizarding World does have a few iconic
items they could use at least for
inspiration you have the Sword of
Gryffindor the resurrection Stone the
cloak of invisibility the Philosopher's
Stone and the mirror of era said oh and
of course the Elder Wand that being said
even Cosmetics can be rewarding if
handled properly after all they did have
the daily and keys quest line which was
the path for unlocking The Relic house
uniforms some of the best uniforms in
the game maybe there's a special
Gryffindor robe that improves the power
of certain spells or Lutheran robe that
makes you more stealth you know I'm
still surprised that the first game did
not lean more into the lore of the
founders as it is largely unexplored
territory and for four of the most
powerful witches and wizards in the
whole series it's almost certain that
they each had numerous Enchanted
artifacts that they left behind now in
that video I made back all the way in
October of 2020. there are a few
requests we had then that did not make
it into the final game such as the
ability for our character to become an
animagus multiplayer and a dedicated
house cup where you earn points but by
far the most glaring Omission that did
not make it into Hogwarts Legacy is
without a doubt quidditch the iconic
sport of The Wizarding World so even
though I don't personally think that we
absolutely need a version of quidditch
in Hogwarts Legacy too I'm gonna put it
on the list because I do read your
comments and this is one that comes up
time and time again so I'll say it for
you guys it would be nice if Hogwarts
Legacy 2 had at least some form of
quidditch for the player to participate
in did you guys know though that they're
actually working on a completely
Standalone Quidditch game already yeah
it's called Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions and you can learn all about it
in the video on the right side of your
screen now in fact some people have even
gotten to play test the game but they
can't talk about it as always guys thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon